apple's legendary september event is
likely less than one month away where
they're going to be revealing their
iphone 14 lineup as well as some other
products so in this video i'm going to
be discussing exactly which products you
should expect to get released as well as
the features for those products but
before i get into all of that i've got
to talk about the date of the event
itself which i think is going to be
happening on september 13th but there is
a chance that it's going to be happening
a week earlier on the sixth we're just
gonna have to wait and see but now let's
get into the products that we should be
expecting of course there's gonna be the
iphone 14 lineup but i'm gonna save
those leaks and rumors for the end but
first let's start off with the apple
watch series 8 which is going to be
announced alongside the iphones at next
month's september event and as far as
the actual lineup this year there is
gonna be three models but it's
completely different from what you
expect the series three that's currently
on sale for 199 dollars is gonna be
discontinued for sure 100 guaranteed and
how do i know this well the new watch
west 9 doesn't even support the series 3
at all so apple's getting rid of it now
the new se is going to be taking place
of the series 3 with a starting price of
279 dollars just like it is right now
for the regular se and as far as the
features the display size and case size
is not going to change at all it's going
to be identical however there will be
upgrades in terms of the specs and
features to match everything we had on
the apple watch series 6 like the s6
chip and everything else except for the
always on display that is not coming to
the sc model and now the regular series
8 apple watch will be basically
identical to the series 7 with the only
changes being internal changes like an
upgrade to the s8 ship potential sensor
upgrades updated bluetooth specs and
more however the display sizes will not
change at all with the cases still being
the same 41 and 45 millimeter sizes but
now here's where it gets very
interesting because we're expecting
another apple watch model to be
introduced this year and i fully expect
it to be called the apple watch pro this
would essentially be a higher end higher
priced watch model just like the edition
has been for years except this time it's
actually getting a bunch of upgraded
features compared to the regular series
8 so let's go through everything that we
should expect first of all it's getting
the biggest redesign since this series 4
according to mark german but he says
that it's not going to be flat like we
expected but it is going to be new and
fresh it's going to have a larger
display according to ross young and i
think it's going to be 42 and 46
millimeter case sizes it's also going to
have a larger battery with much better
battery life compared to the other
models it's likely going to have some
new sensors which might even be
exclusive to the pro model at least at
first it's going to have stronger and
more durable glass potentially
completely flat on the glass panel on
the top it's going to have stronger case
material which will be either titanium
or maybe even a new liquid metal branded
material there's also a chance it could
come with a better display maybe micro
led although the rumors don't point to
that just yet and if not that display
will be coming to a future pro apple
watch model first before any of the
other models and it's going to have a
new high price tag around 800 dollars to
a thousand dollars which will replace
the edition model in my opinion so
that's basically gonna be the new series
eight lineup with the se2 then the
regular series eight then the series
eight pro so that's gonna be nice so
definitely don't buy any apple watch
before the apple event now let's move on
to the next product that we should
expect and i think that's going to be
the airpods pro 2 which could come
alongside the iphones because they're
both going to have matching bluetooth
specs and why well i fully believe that
these will be the first airpods to
support lossless apple music with higher
bitrate making them sound incredible
there should be a big step up in terms
of sound quality with updated speaker
drivers but the design should be staying
the same as before with the short stem
there should be better battery life
better specs better microphones of
course lossless support is going to be a
major selling point and there's a chance
that they're going to be getting a usb
type-c port which is going to be a huge
hint at next year's iphone 15 pros
getting usb-c and in terms of the
pricing i think they're going to be
sitting at around 250 to 300
but there is a chance that these might
come a little bit later in the fall but
to me it makes sense for them to launch
alongside the iphone 14 lineup now
moving on we might actually get an ipad
at this september event which would be
the 10th generation budget ipad which is
finally getting a full redesign with
flat sides to match the rest of the ipad
lineup and because of that it's likely
going to support the second generation
apple pencil with wireless charging on
those flat sides and it's also going to
be getting a usb type-c port finally
however apple is making sure it doesn't
look as good as the more expensive ipads
by keeping the square display around
with the home button and the large
bezels to make sure you know that's the
budget ipad and unfortunately according
to ming chi quo ipad production could be
impacted by power outages so there's a
chance that this ipad could get delayed
until october which is actually what
another korean blogger is predicting
with both the tension ipad and the m2
ipad pro launching at the october event
which actually makes sense because apple
themselves have said that ipad os 16 is
delayed by around one month which should
be sometime in october and now let's
finally talk about the iphone 14 lineup
which will be coming at the september
event guaranteed this year there's going
to be four models the 6.1 inch iphone 14
the 6.7 inch iphone 14 max or plus which
is basically the same in terms of the
specs and features but with a larger
display and battery and then you've got
the 6.1 inch iphone 14 pro and 6.7 inch
iphone 14 pro max model which match the
regular ones but with a bunch of extra
features now all of the iphone 14 models
will be coming with a design that's very
similar to the current 13 lineup except
with larger camera bumps as well as the
pro models finally getting rid of the
notch and replacing it with a whole plus
pill punch design and a super slim
speaker grille leading to much thinner
bezels all of the iphone 14 models
should be getting some upgrades in terms
of the specs like bluetooth 5.2 and
wi-fi 6e and they'll all be getting
upgraded selfie cameras with autofocus
now other than that not much is expected
to change on the regular iphone 14
models but the pro models are where most
of the upgrades are going to be coming
this year
first of all they'll be getting better
displays that go down to one hertz
refresh rate allowing for the new always
on display mode alongside the 120 hertz
promotion feature that we already have
on the 13 pro models which the regular
14s won't be getting they'll also likely
be getting a faster lightning 3.0 port
to support faster transfers and that'll
be necessary because the pro models will
be getting brand new
sensors that can shoot 8k video at up to
60 fps and with that we'll likely
finally be getting 4k cinematic mode and
because of all of that we might also be
getting 256 gigs of base storage on the
pro models but there is a chance that
this won't happen so don't get your
hopes up too high we'll likely also get
some upgrades to the ultra wide camera
and probably upgraded speakers as well
the only downside is that the pro models
will be seeing a price increase of about
a hundred dollars compared to current
prices but i honestly think it's gonna
be worth it for the 48 megapixel main
camera and the removal of the notch but
other than what i mentioned in this
video don't expect anything else to come
at this september event and anything
else is going to be a nice surprise and
bonus so we'll see what happens but let
me tell you i am super excited for the
iphone 14 pro max so if you enjoyed this
video click the circle button to
subscribe and definitely check out some
of those right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
you